البدايه من الصراع الامريكي الصيني وحلقه
جديده من حلقاتها حيث تم الكشف عن تحقيق
لوزاره العدل الامريكيه في تجسس التيك توك
على مواطنين امريكيين ومن بينهم صحفيون
التحقيق مر عليه شهور لكن الكشف عنه تم
الان فالقضيه تعود ديسمبر الماضي حين نشرت
تقارير عن تجسس تيك توك على مواطنين
امريكيين ومن بينهم صحفي في فنان شيل
تايمز والصحفي في موقع باسفيد وموظفين
يعملون معهم وكشفت التقارير عن وصول تيك
توك لمعلومات شخصيه عن المواطنين
الامريكيين ليست هذه المره الاولى التي
تتهم فيها امريكا تيك توك بالتجسس لكن
اللافت كان اعتراف تيك توك حينها بالواقعه
الشركات قالت ان موظفين قاموا بالوصول
للمعلومه بطرق غير سليمه واعلنت طردهم من
مواقعهم الحديث عن هذا الاعتراف الخطير
عاد اليوم للاخبار من بعد انباء عن تحقيق
وزاره العدل يوم الخميس جدد التيك توك
تصريحات حول الواقعه وجددت التذكير بطرد
الموظفين المتورطين في التجسس وقالت ان
تحقيقا داخليا في الامر مستمر وستعلن عن
نتائجه فور انتهاء منهم هذه الحلقه
الجديده من الازمه تاتي في وقت التوتر
الصيني الامريكي في اشده وخاصه ملف تيك
توك فمن اسابيع حضرت الولايات المتحده
استعمال تيك توك على الاجهزه الرسميه وعلى
كل موظفي الحكومه ولحقها في القرار دول
غربيه عده كلها كانت دافعها المخاوف على
الامن القومي والذي تصر التيك توك على
انها مخاوف غير مبرره يوجد اي دليل عليها
ومن ايام قال تقرير لويسري جورنال ان
الحكومه الامريكيه طلبت من شركه بايت دانز
المالكه لتيك توك ومقرها الصين طلبت منها
بيع اسهمها في تيك توك او مواجهه حظره في
الولايات المتحده
ينضم الينا عبر زوم من دبي المختص في
التكنولوجيا كريم فريد اهلا بك كريم لماذا
فتحت القضيه من جديد الان نعرف ان هذه
التحقيقات كانت قد فتحت وفي ديسمبر الماضي
واعلن عن نتائجها لماذا تم فتحها الان
وتحركت وزاره العدل الامريكيه في ازاء هذا
الموضوع من جديد الان
في التسعينات تقريبا كان في كرتون بيتعرض
باستمرار وفي فرين الفرين كل يوم فار منهم
اللي هو اللي مش زاكي قوي يقول للفار
التاني ماذا سنفعل اليوم يا برين والتاني
يقول له سنحاول السيطره على العالم انا
حاسس ان كل حاجه لها علاقه بتيك توك اشبه
بالسيناريو اللي بيحصل بشكل يومي بقى لنا
شهور بنسمع نفس التهديدات نفس نفس
المعلومات تقريبا بتتكرر ولغايه النهارده
ما فيش موقف فعلي جدي من الحكومه
الامريكيه باذاء تيك توك في الشركه على
الطرف في بتجسس بتجسسها او تجسس موظفين
فيها على مواطنين امريكيين على سحره وهي
حاجه بتهدد حريه
المعلومات وبتهدد حريه التعبير
الحكومه الامريكيه عاده بتدعي انها بتدافع
عنها بقوه فلماذا يعني ما اخذتش موقف جد
واكثر قوه نقدر نقول من مجرد التهديدات في
الحقيقه مفيش حد عنده معلومه حقيقيه اللي
بيحصل العدل هذه المره اليس جديا بشكل
كافي
الرئيس الامريكي بنفسه اتحرك في مواقف
سابقه
وتمت مفاوضات وخلافات وغيره وبناء عليها
تم نقل المعلومات المواطنين الامريكيين
حسب تيك توك وقتها لشركات او لسيرفرات
امريكيه على ارض امريكيه فبالتالي الموضوع
مستمر من فتره وفي نفس الوقت بالتوازي
شركات تكنولوجيه كتير امريكيه زي فيسبوك
مثلا حاول الثنائي حاولت منافسه تيك توك
في ملعبها بطرح محتوى مشابه مشابهه وهكذا
ولكن للاسف فيسبوك ويوتيوب الاتنين حاولوا
وما قدروش ان هم يستحوزوا على المستشفى
لكن اعتراف تيك توك بقدره موظفيها على
التجسس على امريكيين وعلى مستخدمين الا
يضعف موقفها في هذه القضيه
بكل تاكيد بكل تاكيد
الغريب غريب جدا في الموضوع الاعتراف وفي
نفس الوقت الاغرب هو عدم تحرك الحكومه
الامريكيه بشكل جاد وبرد اكثر قوه بعض
الاعتراف
الان خيرت تيك توك بين بيع الشركه او
حظرها او حظرها
واعتقد ان الاغلب اللي هيحصل هو بيع
الشركه لاوتر او طرحها في البورصه لشركات
امريكيه لان على الرغم من ان التيك توك
عليه مستخدمين كتير ولكن اذا بعث هيكون
المالك الجديد صيني ايضا ولا حتبيع لشركات
انترناشونال في حاله طرح في البورصه
واعتقد دي المعلومات المتداوله
في مالكين عده او شركاء في الشركه من
جنسيات مختلفه مكان الطرح هيكون هو السؤال
الابرز لو الطرح في البورصه الامريكيه
اعتقد ممكن يضغط هما الامريكيه للتغاضي عن
حاجات تانيه كتير في مقابل ضخ اموال
وسيوله في البورصه الامريكيه
ليس لديها القدره بيع او طرح اصومها من
دون اذن السلطات الصينيه
هذا لا يعرضها لادانه انه هي مرتبطه بشكل
مباشر الى السلطات الصينيه كما تقول
تتهمها امريكا
كلنا عارفين ان هي مرتبطه
بالسلطات الصينيه وتحت
اعمال الحكومه الصينيه
وتؤكد في نفس الوقت ولكن زيها زي حاجات
تانيه كتير احنا كلنا عارفين بس ما بنقولش
ده مباشره الحكومه الامريكيه عارفه بس ما
بتقولش ده مباشره هي ثاني تيك توك بتلعب
دور كبير في الازمه الاكبر الدايره بين
الحكومه الامريكيه والحكومه الصينيه لها
علاقه بالنفوز بالسيطره بالتكنولوجيا
بحركه راس المال وبالمنافسه الاقتصاديه
بشكل كبير فهنا نقدر نقول ان تيك توك مجرد
يعني حجر صغير في هرم كبير هل هل قد ايه
هتقدر تاثر بالتاكيد هتاثر بشكل كبير لان
تيك توك ادى للصين قدره على المنافسه او
ان هو قوه ناعمه للصين ما كانتش موجوده
عندها قبل كده في التواصل مع العالم
الخارجي بلغته فهل الحكومه الصينيه هتفرط
في مصدر قوه ناعمه زي تيك توك او
لا ده اللي محتاجين نشوفه خلال الفتره
الجايه ولكن انتصار الحكومه الامريكيه في
ازمه تيك توك ممكن يكون يغير في شكل
الصراع الداير حاليا
من دبي كان معنى المختص في التكنولوجيا
كريم فريد شكرا جزيلا لك
[موسيقى]